[Music]
in the middle of the sixteenth century
a talented young anatomist named Andreas
Vesalius made a shocking discovery the
most famous human anatomy texts in the
world were wrong they not only failed to
account for many details of the human
body they also described the organs of
apes and other mammals while Vesalius
knew he was right announcing these
errors would mean challenging Galen of
Pergamon the most renowned physician in
medical history but who was this
towering figure and why did doctors
working more than 13 hundred years later
so Revere and fear him born in 129 seee
Galen left home as a teen to scour the
Mediterranean for medical wisdom he
returned home a gifted surgeon with a
passion for anatomy and a penchant for
showmanship he gleefully entered public
anatomy contests eager to show up his
fellow physicians in one demonstration
he caused a pig to lose its voice by
tying off one of its nerves in another
he disemboweled a monkey and challenged
his colleagues to repair it when they
couldn't he did these grisly feats won
him a position as surgeon to the city's
gladiators eventually he would leave the
arena to become the personal physician
to four Roman emperors while his peers
debated symptoms and their origins Galen
obsessively studied Anatomy he was
convinced that each organ had a specific
function since the Roman government
largely prohibited working with human
cadavers
Galen conducted countless dissections of
animals instead even with this
constraint his exhaustive investigations
yielded some remarkably accurate
conclusions one of galen's most
important contributions was the insight
that the brain not the heart controlled
the body he confirmed this theory by
opening the cranium of a living cow by
applying pressure to different parts of
the brain he could link various regions
to specific functions other experiments
allowed him to distinguish sensory from
motor nerves
establish that urine was made in the
kidneys and deduced that respiration was
controlled by muscles and nerves but
these wild experiments also produced
extraordinary misconceptions Galen never
realized that blood cycles continuously
throughout the body instead he believed
the liver constantly produces an endless
supply of blood which gets entirely
depleted on its one-way trip to the
organs Galen is also credited with
solidifying the popular theory of the
four humors introduced by Hippocrates
centuries earlier this misguided
hypothesis attributed most medical
problems to an imbalance in four bodily
fluids called humors to correct the
balance of these fluids doctors employed
dangerous treatments like bloodletting
and purging informed by his poor
understanding of the circulatory system
Galen was a strong proponent of these
treatments
despite their sometimes lethal
consequences unfortunately Galen's ego
drove him to believe that all his
discoveries were of the utmost
importance he penned treatises on
everything from Anatomy to nutrition to
bedside manner meticulously cataloguing
his writings to ensure their
preservation over the next 13 centuries
Galen's prolific collection dominated
all other schools of medical thought his
texts became the standard works taught
to new generations of doctors who in
turn wrote new essays extolling Galen's
ideas even doctors who actually
dissected human cadavers would
bafflingly repeat Galen's mistakes
despite seeing clear evidence to the
contrary meanwhile the few practitioners
bold enough to offer conflicting
opinions were either ignored or
ridiculed for thirteen hundred years
Galen's legacy remained untouchable
until Renaissance anatomist Vesalius
spoke out against him as a prominent
scientist and lecturer his authority
influenced many young doctors of his
time but even then it took another
hundred years for an accurate
description of blood flow to emerge and
200 more for the theory of
four humours to fade hopefully today we
can reap the benefits of Galen's
experiments without attributing equal
credence to his less accurate ideas but
perhaps just as valuable is the reminder
that science is an ever-evolving process
which should always place evidence above
ego for more on the history of medicine
head to ancient egypt and follow along
with the dr. peso shet as she makes her
daily rounds
[Music]